hi everyone
um good afternoon welcome and it
is my absolute pleasure to invite you
all to the
post talk discussion session that we
have
for our monthly colloquium series on
the inference project so as you all know
um
yesterday we had a wonderful talk by
professor jim with the role of um
whether all of university of california
irvine um
and the title of his talk was why do
groups polarize over matters of fact
what models can and cannot tell us uh
so you know we started with
uh and he started with telling us about
these four different approaches
and he outlined the limits and the
advantages
of each of these modeling approaches to
look at highly polarized
groups of people and this kind of agent
modeling
um you know it gives us sort of an
introduction to some of these agent
modeling techniques which
scholars in the social sciences have
often used
in lieu of the kinds of simulations that
physicists astronomers
and people in climate modeling and other
fields uh use sort of simple sort of
numerical models it's a new kinds of
simulations that help us examine social
behavior
so today um it is my pleasure to
introduce our discussant uh professor
kevin dorst
who is on the faculty of the department
of philosophy at the university of
pittsburgh
where he is an assistant professor and
he received his phd from mit uh spent
a year as a junior research fellow at
model in college in oxford
before starting uh this position and
all of his research projects have
centered around one kind of meta
big question which is what should we
think about how people think and
you know typically psychology is a
discipline that is used to
answer this question and psychology
informs us that people's thinking
uh that you know we are actually very
irrational as
people unlike the premise in often
a lot of economic modeling where we are
supposed to make rational choices
but um his work has shown that these
sort of irrationalist interpretations of
data
are actually questionable and they rely
on very simple models of what rational
people
would think and also these two contrasts
of modeling people as either rational or
irrational
and his work has tried to bring much
more philosophically
sophisticated models of rationality
to bear on the interpretation of these
types of empirical results
claimed in order to help assess the
degree
of irrationality and you know how uh
assess how irrational we really are
and so this sort of this this is sort of
his big picture of you
and his um its connection to
polarization in politics is something
that he explores
in his blog post a plea for political
empathy so i urge you all to go
and take a look at it and for an
extended argument that polarization has
its roots
roots in rational causes uh see the
series
reasonably polarized why politics is
more rational than you think
so i urge you to go take a look at his
uh blog feed which is uh
really really exciting and before we
embark on today's discussion um session
i just wanted to remind you about some
of our ongoing projects for which we
would love your input
and one of them is our learning by doing
projects these
simple experiments that can be conducted
by kids
supervised with parents or teachers at
home so please consider
either adding to our roster of
experiments or sending us videos of
your kids performing these experiments
that's saying that our speaker in the
inference series for june uh will be
eric
wiensberg and uh before
further redo i also want to thank our
benefactors
barbara and richard frankie for their
support of the frankie program as well
as many
other activities at yale so
kevin take it away please
thanks so much for um having me in the
introduction i i was telling
jim before the talk this is like ideal
timing for me to
work on some of these computational
models too and have a lot of
big picture questions about what we're
doing when we're when we're doing them
so i was thinking this would be a
opportunity at least for me to to grill
and learn
from jim a little bit someone who's been
doing this much longer than i have and
hopefully it'll be um fruitful
i also realized while rio was giving a
very
nice introduction that i found my first
typo on the handout which is that i
forgot to change the title of this
handout
and so you might with that introduction
and with the title you might think i'm
gonna be going on and on about
rationality and actually that wasn't my
plan
we're gonna talk about a little bit
maybe maybe i'll come back um but
anyway so what i was thinking
i would do just in like the opening
comments questions is uh just refresh
everyone's memory on the three models
uh that jim talked us through last time
trust conformity and reporting practices
and the big picture upshot he was
sketching from them
and then used that sort of upshot and
sort of some of its
pessimism that i think he
rightfully um
introduced at the end as like a
launching
off point for like well to ask the
question what really we
can and should be trying to do um when
we're
using these sort of simple computational
models to try to understand
complex sometimes attractable social
phenomena so i'm gonna
um the handout i think is shared in the
chat
but i'm also gonna share my screen just
for people who don't have it or can't
download it
or walk through the handout together
nothing too
surprising here but just as a anchor for
where
can everyone see that um screen up so
yeah thanks excellent um
so starting just with a summary of what
we talked about yesterday so
uh jim introduced three different models
that uh
lead to polarization from somewhat
possible
causes the first um is trust
dynamics so we have a bunch of little
agents on a network that have some lines
of communication between each other
they have to decide which of two options
to
perform option b or option a
option a they know it's expected value
option b they're unsure of
how good an option is the standard
example is you know
which treatment should i prescribe to my
patients doctors might wonder
and if you're interested in some good
example of this
um jim and kalyn in their book
and i think also in the papers is based
on your detailed uh
case study of uh this uh
what's called the lyme war wars the
debate over whether chronic lyme disease
is
um basically is a thing whether
um chronic lyme disease whether lyme
disease can
that has been treated with antibiotics
can sometimes linger and therefore
get further benefits from further
antibiotic treatment there's a
interesting polarized scientific um
arguably scientific community polarized
on that question uh
and so in that case you might think well
some doctors are deciding whether to
describe do i prescribe antibiotics or
something else
for this patient who may or may not have
chronic lyme so that's the sort of case
which is i think
where this model is most at home um and
the way
this works is that they they learn both
from doing their own
tests or actions they just they take
some options a or b and
learn how good they are and try to learn
whether b is better but they also learn
from their neighbors
their neighbors share information about
how their own tests went and
the the key twist is that how much they
trust their neighbors depends on
how close their neighbors opinions are
to their own in particular
how confident their neighbors are that
option b is better than option a is a
proxy for how much they trust them
and if they trust them less they'll
update less or
you know basically treat their
information as less reliable
than if they trust them more if their
credences are closer
and the upshot is basically that when
trust diminishes rapidly enough
based on how far people's far apart
people's opinions are
we often get polarization one group ends
up pretty confident that a
is better they stop trusting the people
who are using b
and since they're doing a they don't
learn anything else about how good b
is well another group ends up certain
that b is better or arbitrarily
confident that b
is better because they keep on doing b
and keep on eventually getting evidence
that it's
better so that was the first
trust dynamic model and so we end up
with a polarized group because
basically sides don't listen to each
other anymore
the second model was a conformity-based
model so again same structure we got
agent deciding which to do a or b
they're on a network they can learn
from their neighbors that they share a
link with on that network
but now instead of having variable trust
based on the degrees of confidence
agents feel some pressure you might
think of as a social pressure to conform
to their neighbors the people that they
share links with the people they get
information from and can talk to or
maybe trust depending how we interpret
those links
those are the people that they get some
extra
utility or value from doing what those
people are doing if everyone in my
you know social circle is a lyme
literate doctor
as they say and uh prescribes
antibiotics in response to
uh symptoms of apparent chronic lyme
then i feel pressure to do so myself
some and so i might be inclined to do so
even if i don't
believe that chronic lyme is susceptible
to antibiotic treatment
um and there was a basic result here is
that often
this doesn't lead to polarization but
when
the network has a particular structure
in particular one has a click structure
um it can lead to polarization so click
structure is where you have these two
or many different groups that are all
sort of well
interconnected but they are loosely
connected to another group
um sort of like that hopefully you
remember how those look and the idea is
well sometimes when you have this sort
of structure
um you can have a click of people that
are all doing a
and so they're not learning about how
good b is and maybe there's one person
on the edges all these people are doing
a and there's one person on the edge who
this click does b this person learns
from seeing these people that b is
actually better but they don't switch
their action because they feel pressure
to conform to their group
and because they don't switch then um
these people who don't have direct
connections this other group never learn
that b
is better and so everyone still does a
so the idea is basically that
sparse informational connections between
clicks prevent
the information suggesting that b is
better from breaking into this
part of the network and so that's the
way we get polarization
in action and also belief sometimes many
of these people will believe that a is
better
or at least they can um
the third model then no longer had
a network structure it was based on
reporting practices of media outlets and
how those interact or might interact
with people's
response for information and tendency
perhaps to confirm their beliefs
so the model in this case we sort of
model
journalists are observing the world
they're
observing earthquakes or observing
economic consequences
or what have you some um
regular news that they can report on um
that is in some sense
representative on numerical scale in
terms of how severe or how good or bad
they are
and they have different reporting
practices they have to select what to
report and they can
use hyperbole they can make things sound
more extreme than they are
they can use extreme reporting which is
they just they only report on extreme
events one's very far from some uh
expected or neutral baseline
uh or they do fair reporting where they
they sort of like both sides journalism
where they have
whenever they give airtime to a bit of
information
pointing one way they also give our time
to a bit of information pointing
the other
if we take those three different types
of um
journalistic methods and then we add
that the agents watching them have
confirmation bias of a particular form
then we can get polarization so in
particular the the model
confirmation bias is just that um
people sometimes ignore general the
reports of
journalists and how likely they are to
ignore report is proportional
to how surprising they find that report
so they at a given time they have
certain
um beliefs about
basically how how likely you know the
the event there
the economy is to be doing well or badly
or whatever um
and how likely they are to ignore report
to scales with
um how unlikely they they probably
thought the report would be
and the interesting result then is for
certain types of reporting in particular
for
what you might call bimodal reporting
where um
journalists like basically report two
different classes of
bits of information um for and against
more or less so i think that falls from
either extreme or fair reporting or both
jim can correct me on this it's wrong uh
but
basically the idea is certain forms of
reporting that leaves a polarization
because people tend to pay attention to
the stuff that they
the cluster of information that agreed
with them
so those are three just to refresh your
memory on three different um
models of polarization we saw all
rhemaphasia plausible
mechanisms that could be operative and
what's leading to real world
polarization
and so where jim ended his talk was sort
of the question what should we make of
the fact that we've got these competing
models
of polarization and oriented is a point
that i think i agree quite
a bit with but i want to sort of launch
off from that point so
he says like look we shouldn't see these
models really as in competition what we
should see them doing is
identifying different mechanisms
mechanisms which on their own may be
sufficient
for polarization but can also work
together
to create polarization in a given
community so possibly what's going on is
that
all these mechanisms and many more of
the sorts that other
models modelers have made are
contributing
to polarization once we realize that
that's
important and sort of frustrating
because it means that we can't look
at the dynamics of any given model we
have even when we like quite a bit
and read off what will happen by
changing bits of the model
um and say that i'll therefore get
policy interventions from there so the
nice example jim gave was
look you might think look at the
conformity model and think look well the
problem with polarization is that we
don't have enough communication
so if we add more links then the
information will spread to the network
and they won't be polarized anymore
good idea if this is your model but as
soon as you add distrust into the model
like from the first
model more communication actually can be
uh lead to
more polarization there's an empirical
confirmation of that sometimes when you
pay people to
look at uh disconfirming news sources
they they end up more confident in their
prior beliefs
uh so the upshot then is that well look
we have these
we should be very cautious basically in
inferring either predictions or
especially policy interventions but the
effects of those based on any of these
models and we should see them in some
sense interacting
in a complicated way
so i'm going to use that then that seems
totally right to me and i want to use it
as a launching off point for the
question like
big picture question then um which is
sort of
what is the role ben given in light of
that complexity what is the role of the
simple computational models like these
of a complex social phenomenon like
polarization so
in particular given two um
two of jim's observations the first is
that there are of course going to be
many
sufficient and interacting causes for
that phenomenon for polarization
so distrust or confirmation bias or
uh conformity or other things and
jim mentioned this in his talk yesterday
in order to like sort of fully
understand the interaction effects
of those it seems like we would need to
somehow try to combine and sort of weigh
those different factors together into
one grand unified model
but that seems pretty plausibly an
intractable problem or at least we don't
know how to do that well
we know how to make simple models and
analyze their dynamics we don't know how
to combine a bunch of simple models to
make a realistic one
it seems pretty clear that as soon as
you get one marginally realistic
it's either going to be probably both
going to be
computationally attractive but also just
um
inscrutable in the sense that there'd be
too many interacting factors it's hard
to
um know what's causing what um
and so harder and harder to test so
on that sort of pessimistic reading
uh sort of my question of all what
should we be trying to do
when we make a model like this given
given those facts
um and i want to i don't think i have an
answer
i think i have some ideas um i think
we'll maybe raise some possibilities and
ways in which i think they might or
might not fit with um
what jim's thinking what the models he
was talking about are doing and see what
he thinks
about those possibilities if you use
other things in mind
and so on so um first up
option um sort of standard modeler's
option we're giving how possibly
explanations where
what we're doing is basically uh saying
how could it be that polarization arises
and what we want to do
when we are constructing these simple
computational models is delineate
the maybe plausible ways that
polarization can arise in communities
that have various structures once we do
that with enough
different models we have a sort of
catalog a catalog of
sort of that allows us at least in
principle to like assess
the promise or risks of various policy
interventions so we can sort of appeal a
bunch of different models that say well
under this model here's what this policy
would do under this model here's what it
would do and so on
that seems good as a first pass but the
immediate problem and this is something
i think jim
surely agrees with that just there's
just far too many there's far too many
how possibly models um for um
how you could get polarization um just
to focus on confirmation bias i think
there's
more than probably i would think dozens
i think i came up with a list of
half a dozen or more uh different models
of confirmation bias and how it could
exactly it could work and how it could
lead to polarization and
um making different predictions about
what sort of various interventions would
do so we need
we need some further constraints and
just that we're gonna we're not gonna
successfully catalog all these things
at least until we find some way to do
like a meta-analysis of models which i
don't know
question first question is that a thing
i feel like anyways
but um okay so we need more constraints
broadly i think it's
everyone will agree and so then i think
my other questions are basically what
should the constraints
how should we what constraints should we
use or which constraints are useful
to use option two here says well
take the help possibly explanations
constrain them to rational models which
will be no surprise given the title that
i accidentally put on this handout
um so you know one one constraint we
could give is okay
can we show that polarization can or
will arise under
maybe even quite strong rationality
assumptions and that
can be used for one part at least in
part just because
many explanations of polarization appear
to irrational appeal to irrationality so
it can
be pushed back against certain
explanations or show that they're not
necessary
and i do have some sympathy for for that
but it oh
we probably need more concerns as well
it's one one thought but
um i'm not sure question for jim
is that how jim wants to sort of
constrain things
it sounded from the way he was defending
some of the models that he was he was
less
happy to try to um defend them as
rational and the confirmation bias is
pretty clearly not a rational
model even the scientific polarization
of the truss dynamics one
is you know maybe at best a first pass
reasonable
proxy to use distance from your belief
as a measure of trust but
surely would be if you put two people in
a lab in front of slot machines and
they actually follow those dynamics
you'd get pretty nutty results
uh you would think they were doing
something silly um
we can formulate a bottle i don't know
the conformity model might actually do
better on this front so i don't hear
what jim
thinks about that but so that was one
one approach is rational
rationality as a constraint another
constraint we can impose is sort of
psychological constraints
or classical constraints it's like a lot
of importance so sometimes
um psychologists are pretty confident
about
sort of what the specific reasoning
mechanisms are that lead to polarization
at least in certain cases so
there's a good number of fairly robust
if always messy and contested empirical
findings that say under conditions
of this form here's probably what people
do and
that leaves them to confirm their
beliefs so confirmation bias is a bit of
an umbrella term that fits a bunch of
features that have this sort of
structure positive test strategies they
ask questions that they
they expect yes answers to selective
exposure they look for information they
expect
to be confirming bias assimilation when
given mixed evidence they interpret a
way that fits their prior beliefs
uh diagnosticity they tend not to care
about likelihoods in effect if you're a
bayesian
and and so i mean that's contested by
the way um but
all these are congested by the way but
um so there are a
bunch of specific reasoning mechanisms
which
um people arguably do or they sometimes
do
and one role for a modeler then seems
like it could be to like sort of
check the experimenter's intuition that
if they did this
it would lead to population level
polarization sometimes just obvious like
sort of ignoring information that tells
against your beliefs
um and listening information that tells
in favor it's like pretty clear i mean
we can check that
but it's pretty clear that's going to
lead to politicians sometimes it's not
obvious and wrong so one of the
one of the um well-known
instances of confirmation bias is a
positive test strategy people ask in
fact
questions they expect the answer to be
yes to given their
preferred hypothesis um this came from
some waste and selection tasks and so on
uh turns out that just that doesn't lead
to predictable polarization unless
there's some other
error along the way as long as you know
what question you ask then
there's no expected polarization so
that's something that modelers can can
show and so that's one role modelers
can play sort of looking at the details
of psychological mechanisms and seeing
what their effects are population wise
population level
so maybe that's the interpretation of at
least what the confirmation bias model
that
jim talked about is doing but i'm not so
sure and
maybe jim can speak to this as well so
it seems to me that if we're going to do
this sort of psychologically
modeling that it really is quite
important that we
do our best to match the details of the
psychological mechanism in question that
we sort of
you know we have some particular
psychological mechanism we look at
exactly how it works and then
um see whether that leads to
polarization and
i mean i think the you know the model of
confirmation bias that
they use which is sort of being less
likely to update information that
you find more surprising is maybe a good
for
first pass but definitely um there are
many more
details of the empirical story like if
you're a story about how selective
exposure to new evidence
works the many moderators for it jess
wilson has this great
dissertation on confirmation bias which
i take every chance to plug that i can
um and um one just like simple
thing to point out is that there's
insofar as there's a drive towards
confirmation there's also a drive
towards looking at surprising things
uh that's well confirmed in a variety of
other finding uh
scenarios including for example when
people look at what causes
fake news to spread and um
if we model confirmation bias then it's
just being less likely to update on
information that you find surprising
then that's at least in competition with
those other mechanisms where surprises
actually leaves people more
be more likely to look at that
information so um
that's just to say it does seem like
there's a role for the the
computational models and sort of lifting
up computation
psychological reasoning mechanism seeing
what they do at a population level
if we apply them but
it's less clear to me that that's what
some of these models at least
are trying to do certainly oh
i'm gonna ask about i don't know about
the conformity models maybe those are
are closer to them
so i'll ask would james could jump in on
that as well
um okay final final concerns i've gone
for a little bit too long here but um
final thoughts for how we might try to
further constrain the space of possible
models is to
impose further features on the sort of
polarization
where um or model
we observe empirically as a constraint
on what our models should allow us to
predict
um so one feature classic feature
polarization is just people who have
different beliefs and stability so
right but there are many other features
of at least many instances of real world
polarization which we might
um want to try to capture as well
um so consider you know a classic
example of a polarized
empirical question whether capital
punishment has a deterrent effect in
many of the psych studies that
people find confirmation bias use this
sort of
question probably a decently strong
opinion
on that here are i think arguably a list
could be questions
question but arguably three features of
that strong belief you have about
whether or not capital punishment has a
deterrent effect
first it's predictable not merely in the
sense that
it's predictable that people will
disagree about it it's predictable which
side individuals will end up and often
they can predict it too often
even if you're unopinionated on whether
capital punishment has a terrorist you
can predict what your future belief will
be so just take a college student who's
deciding between a super liberal
urban college and a conservative rural
college they can i mean they probably
wouldn't think very much about this but
if they thought hard
and they thought about a little bit i
think they would
pretty confidently predict that if i go
to this liberal school i can predict
that i'm going to be on this side but
anti-capital punishment side of the
debate and if i go to this conservative
school
vice versa um so that's a form of
predictability which is
um much stronger than just predicting
that there will be
two different factions is predicting
which direction to give an individual
will go
um often polarization the second feature
is often profound it's not merely that
they're stable opposing beliefs but
they're basically arbitrarily confident
and that's possibly true of at least
certain maybe capital punishments and
best hard enough fear of questioning
people
a little less confident but anyway so
surely we could find others
here's one that i think maybe is
questionable what i'm inclined to think
is a feature as well
is that many of these polarizations are
robust in the sense that
people's confidence in their opinions
remains
upon learning good empirical stories
about how those opinions came about
so probably most people in this room
have read enough
op-eds and maybe psych studies and
whatever on how
confirmation bias works and uh maybe
they
certainly if they came to jim's talk
they have some idea of how these sort of
models of polarization look they have
some sense of what the social science
looks like when it comes to explaining
polarization
and i take it no one has changed their
belief on whether capital punishment is
insurance
no one's become less confident of that
upon reading some of it in the new york
times about how
confirmation bias works or at least not
significantly less confident
and so that's i mean that's a
constellation of further features that i
think
many polarizations have and then
question do we have models which explain
those features
uh and here's them i'm going to spec you
a little bit
and this will be a good place for jim to
come in as well on here as well but um
i think that the confirmation by bias
model they give has
a and b but not c so a it's predictable
which direction you're going to go you
just basically look at where your prior
beliefs are and what
what media of reporting practices are
are they bimodal or not um it could be
profound because you could
as jim was showing you'd be more and
more confident in your beliefs but i
don't think it's going to be robust and
since as soon as you tell people that
well
what you've been doing is just ignoring
information from the other side
if they're minimally reasonable they'll
just immediately knock down the
confidence of their beliefs quite a bit
um i take it that's not what we do
some debatable just because we're big
headed but we can come back to that
um uh conformity model i think has
c robustness and so you know what the
network structure is
and maybe even an a as well it's
predictable like if you're in a in a
click that's all a doers being pretty
confident you're gonna end up in a
do or at least maybe also an eight
believer i don't think it's profound the
sense that
the reason why we get polarization is
exactly that there's an information damn
there's no more information spread so
people just don't get any more confident
beliefs they just keep doing what
they're doing
i think that's right you may be wrong
about that um
so jim do correct me and the trust model
it seems like well i mean it might it
might depend
i'm not actually sure about
predictability this is the question if
if we start out you know at you know
time zero and we look at
the distribution of beliefs can we
predict who's going to end up really
confident that b is better and who's
going to end up on the sort of
at least with not perfect accuracy but
some confidence not sure
so how's it rambly so i don't know
whether it's predictable actually
um it's profound in one sense one side
is arbitrarily confident the other
thinks that um a is better and there i
think in general just like moderately
confident not they don't get arbitrarily
confident with that
right whether it's robust maybe a subtle
but at least if people
know that what's going on is that
everyone's just
sharing information that they have and
they're just trusting people based on
distance beliefs then they would know
that people are telling the truth and so
they would
uh then update on that information
and so it's not clear how robust it is
to knowing the structure
knowing the cause so
that's my basically not
meant to the criticism per se as the
models i don't know if we really
there's a question whether you even
could have a model that would meet all
these criteria and i think that's a
subtle interesting question as well but
uh
an attempt to maybe try to go from where
we were at the beginning which how
possibly models are too unconstrained so
can we bring in more constraints to try
to um further
uh control the space of where we want to
go or where we want to look and whether
adding these sort of features of
polarization or rationality or
psychological constraints could help
the choice of which models to
investigate so i'll stop there i think i
threw
about 1400 questions at jim i apologize
for those but uh hopefully we can get
some back and forth going about
some of these things thank you so much
kevin uh
that was really um a wonderful
dissection
with many um uh clarifications
as well as uh really important questions
for jim so jim please go ahead
yeah okay thank you so much kevin um for
uh
for putting together um these thoughts
uh there's yeah i mean so there's
there's so much to think about here i'm
actually gonna pull
the handout over to be in front of me
um so that i can keep it as a
guide here um you know i i think
uh there are
a lot of things to say it's sort of a
different at different levels
um so of the options
that you mention um
i i think of this as uh
somewhere between option one and option
three
with a a further possibility for
for um uh development that you don't
mention
so um there's sometimes in which what
we're doing here is how possibly
modeling um because
uh it's it's
these are highly idealized we aren't
trying to
um capture the the details of
the uh uh psychological phenomena
that that were
looking to for motivation or inspiration
um in some cases they aren't even
psychological in the sort of you know
folk sense of psychological they're more
like social psychological phenomena you
know there's
there's seems to be some some tendency
of people to behave in certain ways and
we don't know what the underlying
psychological mechanisms are for that
but it's an observed behavior and we can
extract from that behavior
um some some further information that
could then be a starting point for
for modeling um but the models
themselves uh
are are um
essentially how possibly cameron uses an
expression um
how
how plausibly sometimes she has a paper
where she
she draws a distinction between that you
know there's a kind of modeling where
like what your goal is is to show that
something that someone said was
impossible can happen so
um i don't know if this example will
help anyone but there's a
uh famous claim in the
early 20th century
sort um late early 20th century
uh that um language could never
evolve um because you can't evolve
language without already having language
and um one way of responding to that was
a um game theoretic and eventually
evolutionary game theoretic analysis of
uh how signaling systems can come into
existence
um through a kind of dynamical process
and the claim isn't that this is how
signaling systems actually evolved
it may have some qualitative features in
common with how they actually evolved
but that's not
the point the point is someone said this
was impossible
here's a scenario which you should show
it is possible that establishes that it
can happen now there's further question
whether it did happen
and we're doing something that i i like
to think is a little bit more
than that because no one is going around
saying polarization cannot occur
i mean it seems it seems quite clear
empirically that it does occur
um and so it's more like uh
let's let's um
try to understand whether the various
kinds of hypothesized conditions that
look like they might
be relevant to polarization um
can be seen to
actually bring about polarization um
uh even in simple cases um and so that's
kind of you know it's this is what calen
calls
how how plausibly modeling it's not it's
not just
for the the the pure sake of
establishing um
possibilities but it's a similar kind of
modeling strategy where you aren't
trying
to get anything approaching the full
complexity of the system you're looking
um so
um yeah go ahead yeah it would be great
if we could just
go back yeah yeah cool so there's the
thought there like
um the difference maybe between how
possibly
well at least uh like rule of thumb for
the difference between how possibly
first how plausibly is like
um
is that anyone sort of wow
and how possibly you're just trying to
come up with a mechanism that show that
it could work and how plausibly it's
like people have positive these
mechanisms and we want to verify that
they actually do what people think they
do so it's something
it's something like that i see what you
mean by sort of likes option three it's
a psychological one but it's not
necessarily psychological in the sense
of looking at the details of how
individuals are reasoning or replicating
that it's rather
looking at a maybe a high-level social
psychological tendency and making sure
that
it really is the case that if you know
people only learn from their neighbors
or whatever
people don't listen to people that have
very different opinions than that you
will get
polarization reserving the accurate
that's the yeah that's that's exactly
right so
that's the sense in which you know um we
we try to make the case and you know for
each of the sorts of mechanisms that
we're looking at
that um we are
capturing some of the salient details
that seem to be present
in the real world cases that we're
interested in
and we're asking is that enough um
and that can sometimes happen not at the
level i mean just as you say not at the
level of
uh um sort of
the details of actual reasoning but
rather at the level of what behavior
seemed to result
from the uh
reasoning that that does take place
um and
yeah so so
i mean i think i think you know as you
say there are lots of ways of modeling
confirmation bias there are lots of ways
of modeling trust
too um there are even lots of ways of
modeling how people
change their beliefs or opinions in
light of you know
interaction with their neighbors um
and i mean i i tend to think that even
you know bay's rule is not
i mean no one's doing bayesian
calculations uh
i i'm curious actually i mean i know
that different people have different i
think
uh i think some people think that they
they are
but i'm inclined to think they probably
aren't or they don't need to be at least
in order for it to be the case that um
strict conditionalization
is a good way of modeling the kind of
belief updating
in light of new evidence that agents are
doing
um and so i i would think of
uh the other kinds of you know so the
the kind of
um conformity calculation right we
imagine our agents are performing
a an expected value calculation and then
acting in a way that
um uh they believe will maximize their
payoff in the next round um
are people actually doing that
calculation is that actually what
happens when people conform
probably not i mean there's there's a
kind of um
gut level decision being made i would
think but it's also the case that
there's trade-offs
happening and this captures that kind of
trade-off and you know you can ask well
some of them
yeah some of the neurosurgeons think the
gut level is exactly where all the base
calculation is going from
all the all the yeah all the expected
values are like
manifested as your gut is telling you
but i think
you will not have to go that far too
yeah well so i
um yeah yeah you don't need to anyway um
uh
i mean something has to be happening on
um
oh look i mean if nothing else i mean
you know our our agents have
uh arbitrarily precise
they're not i mean they're they're
floats okay so they've got
64 digit uh precise credences which i
think is probably not perfectly accurate
as a representation of you know human
cognition but i don't think that that
matters for
for what we're trying to do and i think
of the other kinds of
idealizations here as similar right
trying to find something that seems to
have the right kind of
qualitative behaviors at the level
that um they would need to in order for
them to
sort of be playing the kind of social
role
that is being explored in the model
um and so yeah so
that's that's it maybe that that one
question i had
when didn't bring up which is when um
in the confirmation bias model was well
what form of confirmation bias are we
doing is this sort of the ignoring
information or is this sort of being
biased and how you interpret information
am i right in thinking that you're
thinking brother what does it really
matter sort of either
either one is going to have some sort of
effect which has
uh information that doesn't fit my prior
expectations
is going to be more likely to be play
less of a big role in how i change my
belief so maybe it's because i look at
it but then i just count it in some way
that's the biases in life or maybe
because i don't even look at it
and we can we can gloss over some of
this psychological differences there
uh and use this model to explore either
one is that is that how you
think about the conversation exactly and
and i i'm suggesting i mean
there's actually there's another whole
framework for modeling confirmation bias
in the um
yeah the mathematical social sciences
literature uh
where you model confirmation bias is
just having extreme priors
um and you get to then make confirmation
bias a purely rational
thing you know capital r rational within
a particular decision theoretic
framework
uh but it doesn't involve
it you know ignoring or reinterpreting
or
or or changing what data you're updating
on
it involves just updating more slowly
um so
uh you know we're avoiding we're
we're suggesting that that that doesn't
actually have although it's you know
well-entrenched
as a modeling procedure it doesn't seem
to me that it it adequately captures
the salient feature of confirmation bias
of several different types that we think
is is
operative in this case or at least maybe
operative in this case yeah
can i so like when you that seems right
to me yeah it seems like it's not just a
matter of extreme
priors
what do you yes what do you what's the
criteria by which we're then objecting
to that
as a model because like you know someone
could then object as well to the sort of
ignoring data model which is like yeah
that's that is a tendency people may
have but they also have the tendency to
look at surprising things and so like
how do we
how do we um you know whenever we have a
psychological tendency
it's gonna be because humans are complex
and attractive there's gonna be 18
others that we could layer on which may
have
you know may reverse the effect um
so uh i think there are two things to
say
one is that the extent of which that's
true right that
there are other equally plausible things
that i could add on that would reverse
the effect
i i would see that as just a failure of
stability of the model and would
would make me much less confident in
drawing any inferences
at all from from a model with that
character
um but of course you know
like we have we're in a particular
epistemic position
where we know some things there's some
things we worry about some things we
don't know about yet we're trying to
figure out how it works and
you know we're just part way through um
and so you know
these models haven't been fully
evaluated for stability and one way in
which you might try to rule out a
particular mechanism as
a plausible one you have to worry about
is by showing that it's
uh it's not stable under small
perturbations that you think would make
it
um you know more realistic
um all right so the
i think i have a looming like ah but
we don't want to end up with the models
and trackable so we can't keep on adding
things this is a strategy more piecemeal
but we have some model which captures uh
you know this model of confirmation then
there's the question well if you add
like a
you know an interest
in the surprise does that like
counteract the effect and when we can
sort of
we don't want to try to model the 18
psychological mechanisms that could
interact with this but we can take one
and then try adding the second one and
try adding the third one
piecemeal and see whether they so it's
sort of like a
pick from your slew of reasonable
psychological mechanisms and try to pick
as few as you can um
yes although the way that i think about
it is a little bit different just
because
so i think of these models as being um
tools
for reasoning in the sense that um
you have some somewhat vague ideas about
how
things are going to relate to one
another how these sort of you know
psychological or social psychological
phenomena that that you've observed or
that you know you read about in the
literature
how they work and how you think they're
going to work in a social setting and
now you try to
to extract from them some of the
the the basic features that you think
are the salient ones
and you set up a model in which you just
have those sort of simple components and
you see what happens and then you get
these results now you're trying to
figure out what the results mean
um why these outcomes happen what like
what's going on
you start playing with the model and
playing with the model you start getting
a sense of how within the model
interventions are changing things um
which sort of gives you a sense of how
the model's actually working
which then leads you to you know start
thinking about how to interpret
the results generally and how they bear
on like the expectations you had
originally are you surprised by some
things not surprised by some things this
is exactly what you expected in the
first place
and often in that process you start
thinking
oh i see in this model we're getting
this result for that reason
but that's not really what's going on in
the real world that looks like it might
be an artifact
we should try to adjust the model in a
way that
you know removes that artificial
artifactual element
and see if we get the same kinds of
results you know to what extent is the
thing that i
now am worried uh was driving the
results but isn't really
particularly realistic like actually the
thing that's driving the
result and so it's not just uh come up
with a new
mechanism and add that to the model it's
more like in reasoning about how the
model works you learn something about
the phenomena in the first place but
also something about the model
that's it's convincing to me what's that
that seems convincing to me yeah i mean
yeah it's
it's a dialectic process and i think is
i mean i think it's pretty common in
science but
um i certainly had that where like i was
expecting
[Music]
an effect in a model to push one way and
it turned out there was another effect i
didn't see coming which pushed the other
way and then there's out
so that's why that can't yeah anyways
yeah so and i mean i can give an example
from a paper that kayla
is working on with one of our phd
students right now where they discovered
that confirmation bias implemented in
one way in a network epistemology model
improved outcomes
and they were like oh
like what what's happened here
um and it seemed to turn out
that what it was doing was slowing down
learning
in a way that kept transient diversity
in some network structures long enough
for enough data to accumulate
which um in retrospect makes perfect
sense given the way these models often
work
was not at all as i understand it what
they expected and now you have
you know it's sort of a a judgment call
on some level like
to what extent do we think that is
really a possible
uh role that confirmation bias can play
in real world
cases and what would it take to
establish that and what extent we think
this is just an artifact with the
modeling framework
didn't didn't miriam solomon write a
paper arguing that i
i don't know if i've read the paper but
something like that like in the night
like that seems like a cool
uh i don't think it was a computational
paper but it was like
that confirmation bias that had this
effect of sort of
plate tectonics i don't remember the
details anyway so
i don't think i know the paper i think
there's a book
uh by two cognitive scientists
um that uh
i think advances some version of this
thesis
you probably know it um
yeah exactly yeah um
yeah i got a lot of questions that we're
seeing it's perfect but we can oh
that's probably for another time uh
they're really questions for
kailyn not for me
um so there were a few
other things here that i wanted to to
um come back to here
uh so
um so the rational model stuff
uh this is a
i so i think
that understanding how polarization can
arise under strong rationality
assumptions
is um really interesting and important
um i'm not
i mean all of the models that we're
looking at are sort of low rationality
models bound
rationality models or models where
a strategy is adopted that's not even
boundedly rational it's
it's intended to
reproduce some apparently
occurring phenomenon not not one where
we have some background justification
for why that that kind of behavior would
be
um uh rational um
but one that seems to be happening this
is how i think about the trust dynamics
in when you um
we we uh don't
you know scientists don't read papers by
people who they think do
dumb stuff so what's with that
i mean isn't this just part of the
literature i mean well they i mean you
get a waste of your time but maybe you
just think that it's not going to
be be fruitful for other reasons that
you know even if you had all the time in
the world that you wouldn't
actually get reliable information from
from it
um yeah i think that you know in cases
like that you probably can give a pretty
nice full rational
case where you sort of you have a theory
of what the other person is doing and
you have some priors about how useful
it's going to be and maybe you do a cost
benefit analysis or maybe it's
it's that you know you think that this
is all noise no signal and
um but you know we aren't trying to to
model all of that
uh and i think for you know on some
level it doesn't matter for us whether
or not
there's a story that you can tell in all
cases that gives rise to that kind of
outcome
um yeah so
i guess this is sort of a question back
for you which is
um
it sounded to me like if one were going
to adopt option 2 you would need to
believe
that
rationality wasn't just a normative
framework but it was a fully descriptive
framework for
uh human cognition and social
interaction
like are you committed to that i
certainly
don't want to be but i mean i guess
there's different projects you'd be
trying to answer one would be
there's a pure social bismarck question
which is like
does do rational agents polarize
and like you can you can be interested
in that question independent of what you
think about
folks like us now that's relevant in so
far as like
sometimes people will write arguments
saying
well look people are polarized and that
must mean they're being idiots
and so like in so far as it blocks that
inference and it's a interesting
normative factor though and in so far
then is the
mechanisms by which insofar as then we
move we
both have that normative thing and then
can connect it to
various psychological theories and so on
then
then maybe the case can be made it's how
possibly claiming the first sense that i
i discussed right
so possibly right yeah right before we
shift theme we have an
interesting kind of relevant question
from
the audience sanjeev kumar asks do you
think we might be better off focusing on
the contextual features
in other words the nature of constraints
giving rise to polarization
many of the preference based approaches
to learn about
aggregate level features are based on
intentional agents
and so they are making uh you know i
guess the point is that they're making a
strong assumption about
free will do you think confirmation bias
emanates from a high
risk preference that's an interesting
take
either of you take a shot at it go for
it yeah
there are some there are some
papers that argue on some forms of i
don't really understand these papers off
the
top of my head but that are some form of
ambiguity aversion uncertainty about
what your how accurate your beliefs are
going to be something you can be averse
to and that can lead to
something like confirmation by so that's
something like a high risk preference i
don't
and someone at least as far as i
understand some of those models it's
it's a strange sort of ambiguity
aversion and so far as if you're like
have confidence 50 50 in a question then
you there is no ambiguity you know
exactly how
inaccurate you're going to be whereas if
your confidence 80 you're not sure
whether
because you you know the distance
between your degree of conscious and the
truth is 0.5
whereas or whatever your distance metric
is it's the same diagonal side
zero or one whereas in when you're 0.8
it's potentially
different so you're unsure exactly what
your distance is going to be and
layer on some level of i think a risk
aversion such a beauty version
and you get surprisingly you get
something
some sort of confirmation bias now
that's another case where i think
like jim said about the extreme priors
case i think that's an interesting
theoretical result
um it doesn't seem super plausible to me
that that's what's driving
uh confirmation bias for re i don't
think people
i think people with anything prefer to
have extreme opinions rather than
opinions around
point five would be what they have suck
so there's
there's some subtleties there um i don't
know if jim is anything
okay um
uh i i mean the main thing
i i'm sort of focusing on the first part
of the question of focusing
on contextual features like the nature
of constraints
giving rise to to polarization
um and uh
it it does seem to me that that
um so
this is something that came up a bit
yesterday with a question that priya
asked whether or not we can you know we
ever ever sense that that
you know one model of polarization might
be better suited to some particular case
than
than others um and
uh i think that
that the answer is is probably yes and i
think that
the right way of thinking about that is
um that you're you're focusing on
contextual features
and sort of your you know some
background understanding you have
of how the particular
issue is dealt with in the particular
social group that you're talking about
what the nature of the issue is what
kind of evidence is available how
information seems to spread
um and so i think that in particular
cases we can
say a bit more sometimes even quite a
quite a lot more
uh on the other hand um
that only helps a little bit for
some of the bigger picture kinds of
questions that we're interested in and
so as a purely practical matter of what
you're imagining
uh is something like well
you know suppose you have the view
that uh at least some of the
the polarization that we've seen in uh
the us and the uk say in the last
um 20 years has been driven by
new technology oh you mean um the
so that okay polarization not you're not
talking you're talking about the
response to say new technologies
um right so what i'm saying is like like
it's some combination of like the rise
of certain kinds of
cable news channels followed by the rise
of social media
has led to a feedback loop that has
driven polarization
right you might even say something like
well part of the problem here
is intentional decisions made by social
media companies to drive engagement on
their site
so there's a you know they're
incentivized to
maximize time spent and shares and
things like that because that maximizes
ad revenue
and so you want to promote um
highly emotional content or promote
content that is surprising in a certain
way or content that's
you may not even have a theory of why
you just you have an algorithm that
identifies what content seems to get the
most interactions and the most shares
and you promote that more broadly
you might think okay well that's
actually driving polarization now you
say
what kind of policy interventions either
as a social media company or as an
oversight organization
or as a government you want to introduce
right
at that level of description the
contextual factors don't
matter because you aren't worried about
polarization about vaccines or
polarization about covet or
polarization about election results
you're worried about polarization writ
large
and it looks like you know in general
any or all of these considerations could
matter
and um i guess he has a follow-up
question if we use the framework of the
approach
avoid dilemma then confirmation bias can
come from avoidance behavior
yeah fair point yes i see that but you
know i
had a more kind of uh provocative
question for you both i mean
underlying all of these ways of thinking
about polarization
isn't there the assumption that people
are interested in the truth
could it be possible i mean and you know
as a question that is separate
from if we don't conflate that with
rationality irrational behavior and so
on
i mean what if we were to lose that
premise that
that sort of prior maybe there
are people who are not interested
in the truth value um i know that takes
us nowhere
in terms of modeling but i was just
curious
right um it seems like for example
um you know you often watch this is my
one of my pet examples
and um so you know you watch suppose you
go to youtube
and you say i want to watch the latest
spacex satellite launch that i missed
you go and look at it right
and then you know other things that you
might like
right along there uh is a flat earth
society link
that shows up right and that as you just
mentioned jim
and both of you address these questions
like you know social media et cetera
leverage so it's like you know other
related things that you might
these are not assessed for truth value
or anything it just shows up there
and so now this flat earth society years
their
whatever their link has the same
salience in the rank choice search
method that google is using right so
that it's asking you
so and how can somebody
i mean unless you are not interested in
the truth and you're just
looking for an excuse to join some kind
of affinity group
of people who you know people who like
the color red
people who believe in the flat earth or
whatever
i i put all of those i mean it's that
kind of
how do we take that into account and
and that um is there any way we can
model that or is that uh through our
hands and give up
i mean well trigger stuff to say too i
feel like i mean
i feel like it's a great question and
somewhat
complicated one um i think for
for it seem it's definitely right that
people have many motivations that govern
what they see and what how
they think that aren't just figure
things out uh that you're on youtube pro
if you're on youtube you're probably not
like in your peak epistemic in
you know peak inquiry mode you're
probably like at best
sort of having a informative past time
so that's totally right i i think it
as far as my read on the psychological
literature on
motivated reasoning and motivated
cognition and related phenomena that
it it's rarely so simple as that people
don't care at all about the truth it's
rather that they
have other things and then they somehow
those can push them to use
information that can convince them of
various things in certain ways so
you know i'm thinking of i think you
mentioned in the last session some work
by dan gahan as well which shows that
often more polarized people on a given
topic are the ones that
on various measures are more cognitively
reflective or more scientifically
literate they know more about an issue
and they
are able then to rebut problems with or
you know
for but standard pictures and i think as
far as i know the same thing is true in
general of conspiracy theorists that
like
anti-vaxxers or truthers about 9 11 or
whatever are people who in general
know a lot more than i do about vaccine
distribution and production processes
and about what happened on
you know days leading up to september
11th and that sort of thing and so
in general i think certainly
there's room to point to non-truthy
motivations and that i think that's like
some motivation for thinking about
you know jim's models where people care
to conform that sort of thing
or or or other i think those actually
might fit quite well with
some of khan's research um
but i think it it's too easy we make it
too easy on ourselves as the modelers if
we just think that can be
thought of as this person doesn't have
any concern for truth rather it's sort
of
it's filtered in all sorts of subtle
i mean there's a sense in which this is
this is
you know using a certain kind of
decision theoretic framework to describe
what people do um but there's a sense in
which
you know so for instance in the uh
in the the model that uses conformity
that that kevin just mentioned
um the uh uh
they care about some truth they care
about what payoff they're going to get
and their payoff is a combination of
payoff due to their
true or false beliefs
uh their true or false beliefs about um
she's also about to go give a talk
they're true or false beliefs about the
proposition at hand which is going to
have some some
you know lead to some actions and have
some some payoff but also
um they're true or false beliefs about
conformity because i get to pay off from
from that as
as well uh and
you know in some sense
um
[Music]
the way that i tend to think about it is
like
people are motivated by something um and
they care about whether
or not the actions that they take
bring about the outcomes that they want
now they may not be able to articulate
what outcomes they want
the outcomes that they want may not
match up in the way
that you know others as outside
observers would
think of as sort of characterizing the
outcome space
um but there's there's there's some
feedback from the world to any decision
that you make
and if you're just totally wrong about
what that feedback is going to be
um you know it
i guess some people are unhappy but i
mean it you're not it's not it's not
going to work out for you
right
no but i mean i i like um
the um yeah i i like uh i kind of
understand and i get what you're saying
both of you that
you know that it is not it's not like
super useful to think about
people being polarized uh
as some people not being invested in the
truth
at all because it really i mean they're
invested in the truth
but modulo xyz
and i think that's yeah so now i get it
yeah so i think that
um it would not be possible to classify
people's psychological takes as um
you know invested in truth not invested
in truth that's not an
access that's useful yeah
so um i think um
are there any other um questions from
anyone else or um
if not i mean i think we have a little
bit more time we have a lot of uh
you know 10 15 minutes and uh we can
continue
along the sort of uh uh points
so kevin i wanted to hear from you um
what your assessment is of these sort of
agent modeling approaches because i mean
jim kind of
told us what he thinks about their
limits their advantages
and what is your kind of take
of that kind of approach or
do both of you then the open question to
both of you is have you thought about
what other kind of mathematical sort of
quantitative
approach might be useful
uh framework yeah i could i can say it
yeah
i mean i think um i think i'm broadly in
agreement with a lot of things jim says
are very
for for many purposes of you know the
sort of
how plausibly research program he was
describing seems interesting and useful
and sometimes surprising
and maybe more importantly tractable um
i actually come at this from something
differently i come from a um
more analytic formal epistemology side
of things where we're using
um it's much more less computational
based much more proof based much more
detailed
models of detailed rational models of
individual agents it's closer to the
microeconomic equivalent if this is
macroeconomics
microeconomics and
so coming from that background the way i
found
um kind of these sort of computational
models
useful in a slightly different way
or from slightly different angle perhaps
than jim does it
now that you now that i think about
possibly informs most of my questions
which
is uh using the models to lift up those
other techniques so there are sometimes
you have a um
model of how individual and individual
reasons or how they update on evidence
or whatnot
but it very quickly becomes interactive
when you think of how they're going to
do it over a long period of time or
maybe with many other interacting agents
not something you can
write down proofs very easily about
at least except in very special cases
and so the
one very useful thing for a
computational model is that often you
just simply
simulate it and see what happens um when
an agent who acts in this way
which you've specified and argued makes
sense or whatever or at least
actively describes psychology in this
sort of scenario see how that that will
evolve over time and this is
the thing i mentioned earlier with jim
where i you know analytically had some
hunch that
would go one way and in fact once you
simulate it goes a different way because
they're multiple competing factors so
that's one way in which i feel like it
it
can be useful not not i wouldn't want to
say certainly the only way but
as a way of lifting up either
psychological or
other motivated sort of microeconomic
style models of individual reasoning and
seeing what the effects are
when iterated or writ large um so that's
i mean that's the way i combine some of
some different mathematical techniques
with uh
computational ones um
i also have a list of other questions i
can pepper gym with if we want to
i mean so i'm i'm hearing previous
question in part
um in the context of um
you know how to think about agent-based
modeling in comparison with
various simulation methods in other
areas of
science yeah um
and so you know
even in the kind of example that kevin
just discussed there are a few different
things you might
be thinking of doing with the simulation
right so one is you just have some
computationally intractable
problem and so you solve it numerically
and that's the sort of thing that we
sometimes think of as a
simulation in some areas of uh science
um you might also think about
you know um
yeah yeah okay so we just
leave it at that um you know there's
sort of a
general slew of different computational
techniques that you could bring to bear
on problems um and you know there are
uh sort of intermediate cases where it's
not totally clear
whether you should think of something as
an agent-based model or not
um the way i usually think about
asian-based models is that
uh you are i mean
you're you're you're thinking of them as
um uh a collection of
individuals parameterized in some way
that have some dynamical properties
uh you know
arguably cellular automata are
asian-based models on that
definition but that's not that's not
people how usually people think about
them and so you know okay so just what
is it that makes the
nature-based model really an agent-based
model and i'm i think you can very
quickly come up with
um counter examples to virtually any
definition you could
could give even though we have a pretty
good general idea about how they work
um but i mean look you know think about
like
you know um particle mesh type models in
cosmology
there's a sense in which we're talking
about particles but it's also the case
that we aren't representing
particles we're representing regions of
phase space and that they behave kind of
like particles from one point of view
right and so you know there's some sense
in which this is a
uh just a numerical method for solving
certain
complex differential equations um
which themselves have an interpretation
as governing small bodies acting in the
collective
um but you know um
i mean there are proxies they are
proxies with convenient properties for
numerical manipulation
basically right
no because i i wondered whether i mean i
guess
part of my question is whether you know
is there a just an
information flow approach
um that could be used
um could we just make maps of
information
flow and you know intersections between
those maps collisions between those bits
of information or whatever
i'm just trying to see if there are you
know if
one were to model
what is it the transmission of that
causes
that ends in polarization and so on i'm
just
you know um freewheeling here trying to
see
what kind of approach might be an
interesting
new way because you know one of the
goals of our longer term project is
really to try
sort of try and understand what are the
ways in which we can
depict complex processes from which we
are able to pull out
causation we're going to infer causation
from correlations and deeper
correlations how do we
kind of how do we characterize complex
systems
in terms of the causal relations between
entities that are part of the
modeling scheme so i was just curious
like in a meta way
you know is there a sort of another
are there other approaches we could
consider
yeah i mean jim might know more on that
and
i i feel like i sort of sometimes think
of the some of the agent-based models
that
jim was describing as doing something
like giving a map of information through
how does information flow uh flows from
people saying and doing things
and so when we think of and people are
connected in certain ways via
maybe networks of trust or communication
or
interaction and then we can model that
as you know social
sort of like the you know the the two
models jim was using the first two
controls so the network graphs kind of
models right the network
graphs kinds of models of uh
maybe driven by uh uh computational
um uh tractability considerations
but where you go from uh
very complicated networks and very
simple rules for how information
propagates on the network
to very simple networks maybe just a
single agent or a small handful of
agents and complex psychologically
realistic models of how
uh those agents process information yeah
which are themselves often network
models right you know like a bayesian
network representing
the single agents right but that you're
you're sort of
um you know there are modeling
frameworks that
uh use very very simple dynamics for how
information propagates so for instance
um
epidemiological models are often used in
social epistemology
less so by philosophers but often by
psychologists
social psychologists to study the flow
of
um information and what happens is
basically you know you have either some
very complicated network or just
random pairwise interactions and there's
some probability of some
transmission you can think of that as
modeling information flow through a
network or through some population
kevin we do have a few more minutes so
if you have any
um last points that you would want to
discuss and bring up with jim please go
ahead
yeah i mean there was one i mean uh
small questions i threw out jim which
maybe i won't bore people with but that
there's one question i had that
related to what jim was saying at the
end of his talk that may be somewhat
less related to some of this discussion
but
um and so far as he
was worried about this you know the
initial worry for the three different
models explaining polarization was
uh well are they competing uh they're
they giving different explanations
and so does that mean they're in
competition in some sense one question i
had when
through the models at first was um
basically to what extent we can see them
all as arising from one root cause which
is
is is trust in some sense so like when
we think about the conformity
model in particular like in many
contexts like what what does a link
represent
in a context where um or want to model
these people as doing a or b
and they're learning from some people
and not others well
if we're thinking about a political
reason like that it better not just be
lines of communication because
communication
is cheap everyone can commute with any
everyone nowadays it's got to be
something more robust and one natural
thing is
the lines of trust they're the people
that you listen to and so like
in this little model the reason why this
there's no link between these two is not
because this person can't see what this
guy is shouting it's just that this
person doesn't trust that person
um on that interpretation then it looks
like the
conformity network
models might have very similar
motivation
and very similar driving force
underlying them
to the trust dynamic ones and likewise
you might even think with confirmation
bias why is it that you
people tend to disregard information
that they find is surprising well big
reason is that they don't trust it like
when when breitbart comes out with a big
news story about like what the clintons
were doing in
you know mid-90s or whatever i think ah
that's pretty questionable i'm not
probably not going to listen to that
because that and the reasons i don't
trust them as reporters
um and so
i mean maybe you know that's a
unification without
the potential to get unification a name
without unification substance i mean
trust can have very different
meanings in different contexts but i was
wondering if
there is some deeper unity that could be
had within these
class of models in some sense trust
drives
yeah i mean i think that there are a lot
of interesting things that one could
say or think about more here um one
remark is just there's an interpretation
of the trust model that we presented
where it's a dynamical network model and
really what's going on
is we have um either you know
everyone is connected to everyone but
the strength of connection moderates
over time as a function of distance and
belief
uh um or you could even think of
of it being a kind of a literal distance
you know people are
are arranged and some uh
um grid and uh
move in belief space over time and
listen to others
based on their actual distance in that
space
do you all see the scary new york new
york times at a thing that like
mapping polarization within cities like
within cities you see these like massive
uh red and blue sections so once this
came out earlier this year it's
fascinating
yes like literally space sometimes
correlating
right but i mean there's also there's
the like what's the causal direction
oh yeah yeah it was all there right yeah
but i mean
i i think so so i think that there's
something to that nonetheless i
i also think that um
you don't need to think about the uh
connections
in the um conformity model
as representing trust you can interpret
them
as for instance literal geographic and
you know
inaccessibility or you know there's been
a lot of theorizing
about what happens on the internet some
of which have been debunked actually but
um where you know you have this idea of
filter bubbles where there's
literally um you see different content
and you you it's very difficult to gain
access to the other
kind of content um
and you know
that leads to an interpretation of the
conformity model
where it really is that you're not
seeing
everything that other people are putting
out you're right that it's not that you
can't
in principle overcome that um
but uh um it's sort of the first order
not what you're exposed to
and so i think it's interesting that
even if you don't have i mean
there may still be some underlying level
at which trust is coming in like
why is this the social network that
you've built or
why is this um you know
why has your what they call um a
news diet or media diet shaped in the
way that that it is
that has to do on some other level with
with trust
um but it turns out that just you know
differential exposure is sufficient even
if it's not trust based
and so i think that that's an
interesting upshot
um even if there's some you know other
underlying explanation that makes this
really more about trust and it's
presented in the first
instance
yeah yeah that sounds like one could
defuse
even if one could diffuse the worry that
these models are incompatible by saying
well they all actually stem from the
same thing
it's maybe not wise to because the
general point about even if they
did have different causes even if we
certainly interpret this as geographic
location or whatever then uh they could
be the point that they can be sufficient
not competing in interacting causes
would be right
we seem to be at a moment of uh natural
pause let me quickly check if there any
other questions have come up
um in the chat i don't
see anything um so
i i i guess um it's time to say
thank you to both of you for a really
nice
um useful clarifying and
fun discussion wouldn't it be wouldn't
it be wonderful
if we had uh a solution
to uh helping um understand
uh polarization i think you know
polarization is probably
inevitable to some degree or the other i
guess it's part of human psychological
emotional intellectual diversity that
we may have to live with but the kind of
extreme levels of polarization have been
so detrimental
to society and culture and in particular
the polarization around science and
around facts
and reason have been deeply disturbing
in the last couple of decades so
i want to thank you both kevin and jim
for
this really wonderful afternoon it's
been a real privilege
to listen to both of you discuss
and it's a treat that we were thankfully
able to replicate in this virtual
situation
and in many ways i think while the
pandemic has
really thrown a number on many of our
approaches to interacting and convening
one of the good things has been the
reach
and the possibility to get people uh
without leaving a common footprint well
not as big a carbon footprint um took to
convene and converse so thank you both
uh
to uh and bye uh to irvine and
in pittsburgh um uh
and have a wonderful um uh weekend
uh a long weekend thanks everyone i want
to
thank the audience for attending and
participating in this
uh fabulous event and i want to thank uh
tai for helping organize this and to
guide for helping with all the av
so bye everyone have a look bye
everybody
thank you